like two seconds for dude
he's gonna move he made it with two
seconds left
he's quite a cool customer still isn't
he i mean like
he's not looking that cool actually
i say he's pretty cool but i mean there
is a limit oh
wow i think it's a big mistake and look
at this black can continue pushing his
pawn because now if white's rook goes up
to capture one of the black pawns this
pawn will continue pushing down the
board black is almost about to make a
new queen and how does he do how's he
always do it magnus i mean you always i
always think oh he's gonna struggle to
you know draw this one and then he goes
on to win yeah
maybe there's a few winning moves but
black can push his b pawn forward now
connect those two there we go the points
connect white can't take that pawn with
his own pawn because the black queen
would pounce and take the white rook in
the corner
these two black pawns are just going to
win the game white's king coming trying
to ride to the rescue but it's not going
to be enough look at those two pawns if
whites goes and captures a pawn now
there's going to be a check from the
black queen and white's rook is going to
drop
that one of those two black pawns is
going to cost white the rook magnus is
going to win harry and barry seconds
five seconds and
he might lose on time here he might just
lose on time because he's lost anyway i
mean is that it is it over yeah it is
over okay did he actually lose on time
or did he just resign i think he just
let his clock run out because uh it's a
hopeless position anyway what a dramatic
start to the oslo esports cup you guys
the bar been shifting from side to side
but eventually magnus carlsen wins game
one